BMW has debuted a new motorcycle
the s1000xr the Bavarian automaker is
riding high at the moment when it comes
to motorbikes sales and profits are
soaring so we've brought an expert in to
put the new BMW through its paces
Stefan sheds ax he says it's his first
time on board the new BMW s1000xr it's
an adventure bike based on the model of
the s1000r roadster and he's keen to try
it
the recent models by BMW Motorrad are a
big part of their current success the
new s1000xr is intended as a cross
between a sports and a touring bike BMW
is calling the new breed the adventure
sport the four-cylinder engine is
derived from the sport roadster s1000r
it's a straight 4-cylinder engine with a
displacement of 999 CCS and output of
118 kilowatts
Maktoum of BMW Motorrad says it's an
adventure sport so it's an all-rounder
that combines the sportiness of the
s-line with the qualities of a touring
bike so this bike lets you go on long
rides much like an enduro but it also
has the touring bike side combined with
a sporty DNA you see through the entire
s family what they can gain and DT gonna
say is family ups the s1000xr also
features perfect ergonomics increased
ground clearance an optimal wind and
weather protection
doom says the geometry of the frame was
slightly modified and adapted that
starts with a steering head where the
angle is slightly shallower the fork is
thirty millimeters longer because the
bike is higher in front the wheelbase
has quite a bit longer and there's a new
swing arm it's 69 millimeters longer
which gives you a wheelbase that's 100
millimeters longer and all and that
gives ride stability a boost WTA 20
photographs and driver safety has also
been given a boost with electronic
safety features the rain and Road modes
come as standard and help adjust the
ride characteristics to the road surface
an added extra is the Pro Mode which
includes the ABS Pro which provides
additional safety when braking in a
banked position even when the brakes are
applied sharply the wheels don't lock up
and that reduces abrupt changes in
steering force
the week doom says the major advantage
of ABS Pro is how it processes signals
in a bank position so you can control
the bike even when you brake on a curve
and the bike stays stable that's true if
the rider is caught off guard and breaks
very abruptly there's no way to change
the laws of physics but this system does
take advantage of all the options in the
embarrassed American diva from the DNC
physic pitted Stefan said so was back
from his test ride so what's his
impression
he says it's very sporty a bit higher
and not quite as athletic as the s1000r
it's sporty so you can't write it like a
GS coasting and high gear won't give you
rpm but hit the gas and you'll really
move that is methodical diversity keep
it if dictionary